[Musique]
ma place trop je suis artiste peintre
j'ai 40 ans je suis originaire de
la banlieue nord de paris
j'ai commencé le graffiti à 20 ans
maintenant je suis autodidacte de a à z
c'est par l'évolution par la progression
que j'ai j'ai réussi a finalement accédé
à des façades et les projets plus
conséquents
[Musique]
nous sommes heureux
cette année j'ai pas le château de la
belle valette
je connaissais pas mais je connais c'est
juste le château en photos de pas aux
autres artistes qui l'avait fait avant
moi j'étais jamais venu sur place
mais compte avant cette édition en fait
on le fasse
je n'avais pas de bonnes idées à faire
dessus donc j'ai attendu j'ai préféré
attendre d'avoir une bonne idée c'est
plusieurs maquettes avec plusieurs
déclinaisons de couleurs au revoir celle
qui percute le plus le choix et leur ca
dépensé sur le plaisir en bien au final
celle que j'ai choisie je trouve que
kaka c'est bien l'architecturé de base
qui avait pour en mettre une autre la
mienne donc
[Musique]
certainement des enfants noirs parce que
le noir annuler vachement les défauts et
les reliefs les lignes autres que celles
que je vais tracé c'est à dire les
lignes qui est qu'ils sont existants par
l'architecturé du bâtiment peuvent
trahir mon illusion puisque j'en cherche
en créer d'autres
pour moi un projet réussi c'est lorsque
l'illusion à fonctionne fort lorsque les
gens ils sont bluffés par les visions en
fait
[Musique]
j'étais honoré qui me fasse confiance
pour ce projet ça n'arrivera pas deux
fois je pense n'est pas un château ça
sera le seul et unique engage à rien
[Musique]
comment son intérim j'me récente et cela
me pèse vivre ma vie comme louise était
dumas et c'est pas nouveau loin faut le
faire
ça fait plus d'un an que je vois leurs
noms que je dois mes plaies
ça fait quoi le tout à fait
le seul vrai dégâts sim ainsi qu'aux
souvent quand je voyage pour faire une
grosse façade quand j'ai un jour ou deux
drames à la fin au lieu d'aller à la
plage avec les mecs de la ville où on se
trouve un mur dans la ville on va faire
un lettrage avec l'esprit qui me reste
ça c'est toujours c'est c'est le
défouloir c'est le moment où on va
pouvoir faire ce qu'on veut qu'il ya
plus de règles de murs sérieux c'est un
mur la récré
[Musique]
l'idée c'est de remettre en remettre en
lumière des débats de 6 d'exception à
l'abandon avec un projet de transition
qui tourne autour du street art et du
graffiti
astro c'est venu assez naturellement
saint-narcisse à qui on a déjà travaillé
on adore son travail et on voulait
vraiment quelqu'un de l'ancienne
génération du graffiti et à astro est
une légende est une légende aujourd'hui
dans le graffiti et on s'est dit que son
style l'illusion d'optique c'est quelque
chose qu'on n'avait pas eu pas eu encore
et sur une bâtisse comme ça c'est un
sacré challenge lui qui est habitué à
travailler sur des murs à plat et du
coup on saisit une naturellement
instruire
[Musique]
bd la
bonne
hamoud abdi la hauteur
hamada
telle a bottle